okay so can we just like chill for a
second and talk about the insanity of
this recent Dragon Ball news so the
story here is that for a while now
Dragon Ball's rights holder shueisha has
had a department dedicated to the
direction of Dragon Ball named the
Dragon Ball Room and the head of this
department was one Akio iyoku now iyoku
is known for let's say specific
Tendencies he is very rooted in making
Dragon Ball appealing in a specific way
Nostalgia trunks returning Gohan Beast
Broly all pushed by him so fast forward
to now and there was talk internally
that eoku was too possessive of the
franchise and may be moved to a
different department so instead iyoku
decides to leave the Dragon Ball Room
and start his own company named capsule
Corp Tokyo and even crazier than that is
requesting that he gains the rights to
Dragon Ball's future anime movies Games
Etc how does he expect that to happen in
what world I ask but I guess like go off
King